in this video we'll talk about
klebsiella this is a high heel topic for
USMLE step one stay tuned till the end
so clipsy Allah
is a gram negative Rod that can cause
significant infection in humans
klebsiella can be found
populating the oropharynx or intestine
in normal scenarios but sometimes they
are overpopulated and they can cause
disease
one of the most common disease that is
caused by this particular genus is
pneumonia
so in this video we'll talk about the
classification and characteristics of
klebsiella
then the clinical presentation
then risk factors and epidemiology and
finally we'll talk about the treatment
option but before we start let me tell
you a quick mnemonic to understand the
overall idea about klebsiella and this
mnemonic is a b c d e of klebsiella a
stands for aspiration pneumonia b stands
for abscess in lungs and liver
and C stands for current jelly-like
sputum
d stands for diabetic
and E stands for etoh overdose diabetes
and etoh overdose are significant risk
factors in this case
okay so let us talk about the
classification and characteristics of
this bacterial genus klebsiella belongs
to the family enterobacteria C that
means they are some somehow found in the
intestine and they are drum negative
bacillus they stain pink in the gram
staining
it is a facultative anaerobe that means
it prefers oxygen but it can live
without oxygen as well
I mean it can survive in the anaerobic
condition the genus includes several
species with klebsiella pneumonia the
most relevant uh in a clinical
perspective
klebsiella pneumonia has a prominent
polysaccharide capsule which plays an
crucial role for them to evade the
immune system so here you can see there
is a capsule on the outside which
prevent the phagocytosis
of this bacteria via macrophage or let's
see dendritic cell and that's how they
can evade the immune system
now let's talk about clinical
presentation clipsial and pneumonia
commonly cause pneumonia individuals
with underlying conditions such as
alcoholism diabetes mellitus chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease COPD or
many other diseases are very susceptible
towards klebsiella infection
and the classic presentation includes
sudden onset of cough and cold with a
current jelly like sputum which exactly
look like red jelly
then this jelly is typically mucoid and
reddish brown in color
there could be fever which has a sudden
onset
pleuretic pain
then cough and thick Mutual mucous putum
and eventually it might have shortness
of brain now when the infection is
severe then this kind of shortness of
breath is visible cyanosis and death can
occur even in two or three days in
extreme situations
can cause
meningitis liverapsis soft tissue
infection and bacteremia
risk factor and epidemiology includes
immunocompromised States so individuals
who are immunocompromised are more
susceptible towards this infection
people who have diabetes and alcoholism
study shows that they are more
susceptible to klebsiella infection
then let's talk about the risk factors
klebsiella infections are commonly found
in icus because icus are highly aerobic
situation and that's very good for these
bacteria to grow that's why people might
have Hospital accurate pneumonia which
is caused by ecclesiella pneumonia
when it comes to treatment option
klebsiella pneumonou strains are often
resistant to multiple antibiotics like
the classical beta-lactam antibiotics
like third generation cephalosporins so
the treatment option might include
carbapinims fluoroquinones and
aminoglycosides
but the big concern about klebsiella is
its antibiotic resistance and there are
many antibiotic resistant strains
throughout the world
and this is significant concern for the
clinicians the emergence of carbon epine
resistant klebsiella pneumonia is the
big Global Health Challenge
this particular strain Secrets One
protein known as carbapinimase which
breaks down this antibiotic and thereby
neutralize the threat
and that is why it is so hard to treat
it is increasingly getting hard and
difficult to treat klebsial infections
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick Thumbs Up Get
notes and flashcards in our Facebook and
Instagram page you can support our
Channel using super tanks you can pay
via paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video
foreign